[Music]
on Mondays episode of The Bachelorette
tension was so thick you could cut it
with a thorn becca cou friends remaining
suitors participated in a beck election
which meant a debate which meant things
got nasty especially between Lincoln and
Chris not ones having crossed my mind to
pack my bags and go home like Chris
there's a nasty side of Lincoln that is
very I would say malicious and
aggressive we were having a conversation
yesterday and I said that I would want a
two on one and follow us up against
Lincoln I feel like it would be an easy
road that translated into Lincoln
calling me a that behavior didn't go
over well with Becca she confronted both
guys and then they confronted each other
again it's unfortunate but you're mine
later Chris headed to beca's hotel room
and the outcome wasn't great there's
been a lot that I've heard a lot that
I've seen in the past couple days not
even around you but hearing things and
it scares me my relationships and
picking them apart and there are some
really solid strong relationships and I
don't think that we're there and at this
point I don't think that we'll get there
and to make matters worse Becca and
Chris ended on this awkward notes I'm
gonna walk you out because you deserve a
and
Levi don't walk out well I don't think
you need anything but I'm gonna give you
that respects
you